are all video games bad find out on this
episode of led live
[Music]
exposing darkness
thanks for tuning in to another episode
of led live today we have a special
guest named jared bowling and he is the
founder of a new prophecy video game
that we'd love to talk about
so on our channel i'm sure you guys have
seen us talk a lot about the negative uh
versions of video games in fact we've
made quite a few documentaries and video
projects on the negative aspects of a
lot of video games um but i'm actually
excited to kind of get into this topic
of a positive video game and something
that is a teaching tool to teach people
prophecy
like that's kind of crazy
and not just any prophecy but bible
prophecy okay so i'm excited to hear
about this so uh jared how did you even
first come up with this idea
you know what to be honest on i just sat
around for a long time and i was like
man wouldn't it be cool i don't know if
you guys ever had this idea like
wouldn't it be cool if there was a bible
prophecy video game that had a lot of
theology and brought someone to christ
and got them in contact with their local
churches and so i just had this idea for
maybe about five or six years and i just
waited for my favorite ministry to say
hey uh we're gonna make this cool video
game and so i had all these notes of
like four or five years of notes i would
just keep notes and then eventually last
year i was like well i guess i'll uh try
and make this game
nice nice yeah i didn't i didn't think
about video game but i know a thought of
mine and a lot of my pairs is man why
can't prophecy be simpler to understand
why can't it be explained in an easier
way and i can see video games as a good
conduit to achieve that for sure it's
really interactive you know a lot of
ways to memorize things is well for one
through song but for another
making a game out of it you know so i've
heard some of your ideas about you know
how you make a puzzle of how to memorize
a certain prophecy like the statue of
nebuchadnezzar or something turn into a
game and stuff uh you know mix and match
and that kind of thing it's really
pretty cool and i and i hate to call it
a game too i mean it is technically
classified a game but to me it's like a
interactive movie okay
so it's like something that you're a
part of something that's ingrained into
your mind because you not just watched
it not just read it but you took part of
it and so it's more locked into your
mind so um
excuse me but i haven't played a lot of
video games
but is this kind of like you know where
they have a story line and so you're
sort of following the story line so is
there some sort of cinematics with this
as well like well you know what what
what's the kind of like game going to
look like yeah yeah um definitely going
to have to go all out right it can't be
cheesy it can't be lame it can't be
corny where you know real gamers real
gamers like people that are playing call
of duty right you know this is the
audience people that play video games um
three billion people on this earth one
third of the earth well a little bit
more than one third of the earth's
population is playing video games
and so i'm gonna try and tap into that
with the latest greatest graphics while
integrating the storytelling mode um you
know i love to go to revelation series
or um watch revelation series have you
guys ever seen a revelation seriously
yeah um amazing facts just got done with
one with uh called
panorama of prophecy
and i like the layout of it it actually
tells a story within itself it starts
out with daniel 2 and the statue and it
brings on to the
person watching it trust in the word of
god uh ability to understand bible
prophecy and then also of course you
know the main part of daniel 2 is the
rock and so there's a lot of people that
haven't really been introduced to that
concept of uh
the daniel 2 statue and so i want to be
able to bring the truths of bible
prophecy of revelation 1 1 and to bring
it to the gamer very cool super cool in
the beginning you said something about a
game about prophecy and you said bible
prophecy like you clarified that it was
bible prophecy and i was thinking is
there any other prophecy but a lot of
games i've noticed and movies we were
just talking about this yesterday the
the matrix um star wars there was
literally they talk about prophecy like
the prophesied one he's the one and
we're talking about
star wars in the matrix so there
this concept of prophecy is tied into
video games movies and stuff but it's
the wrong prophecy it's a false prophecy
so it'd be cool you know that should be
gravitating towards a gamer when they
hear these kind of words like oh cool
it's like this epic journey about a
prophecy these are things that people
are familiar with already but they're
going to learn the truth but it's true
it's not made up that's what's cool
about it i think you know there's
actually a
a
a much greater spiritual um you know
sort of
um magnificence about this learning that
you know is what's really going on
behind the scenes
and following what's actually really
happened in history and i mean this is
going to be amazing teaching tool yeah
prophecy is not just in the old
testament but it's also found in the new
testament and it's found after the time
of christ through the reformers of our
church and such that's true you know um
he said that there are three billion
people who are
three million gamers wow that's
it brings a memory um i was on instagram
and i saw this video of this son he was
older but he wanted to give back to his
family to say thank you for everything
that had transpired during his life so
he got his father who looked like in 50s
maybe 60s
christmas gift and it was the ps5
it's like the the father's inner boy
came out and he started crying he was so
grateful for this video game and i was
like whoa like you're older but you're
like really excited to to play this game
or to have the system to be able to play
games
um what's your audience for this
this video game because i mean there are
babies playing this and then there's
like 70 year olds playing it as well um
just in invested in the gaming world so
how are you able to cater first what is
your audience and how are you able to
cater to them and a wider audience as
well i love that question i got some
statistics we can go over and we can
look at what that audience looks like
great cool okay cool um
before we kind of get through to that
audience you know i like to look at the
history of how mankind has received
knowledge you know first starting out it
was by word of mouth
and then the intelligence of mankind
kind of dumbed down and then that's
where we see moses writing the first
five books in the bible saying okay
now it has to literally be written out
and then um fast forward
the written format has been the longest
way of learning something either
edutaining or
something that's personal or even
theology
and then here we are in the end times as
i like the bank and technology is just
here and how are the main people
learning today um are they yeah yeah
right i mean yeah right and so um
and so i i think i think if we look at
the main
focus of what people are putting in
front of their eyes if we can kind of be
able to get bible prophecy into
front of their eyes then um
i think it'll make a huge impact
well we just that was also in a show we
did yesterday we were looking at
somebody who was a like an english
professor at a college was saying
that media is the most impactful way to
get your message through and he was
saying that movies are portraying a
spiritual message so that was that was
really to prove our point that we say on
this show all the time that media does
have an impact there is a message in
there and they're actually admitting it
but uh yeah straight from the horse's
mouth and he said
the spiritual message is reaching people
more through media than ever with
synagogues and churches and all these
things
yeah right the media is going out to
where um
where the word is has a tough time going
to right well and i also think like you
know people realistically go to church
maybe one hour out of the week and the
rest of the week you're exposed to all
kinds of different ideas and things
throughout the week and so you know
you're basically bringing these ideas
into their world
and hopefully you know leaving a lasting
impression on on you know what those
truths are
yeah majority of people as we go through
the statistics well you know they're
spending all of their time watching all
of this other content maybe like you're
saying getting in that hour of church
but then throughout the week what are
they receiving and then when you take
the theology or their biblical beliefs
and then take what they're learning on a
daily basis whether it's in school or
what they're watching and then when you
mix it and match it it kind of
something's gonna give right
and on that line of thought in the anime
documentary we talked about a game
called shin megami tenshi
and it was literally a satanic bible
study interactive like you're running up
the stairs to heaven and you reach a
door and god's like no
turn around repent now and it says do
you wish to continue yes or no and the
player has to actively hit yes i want to
continue to the point where you finally
reach god
this head that is yahweh it says his
name is yahweh
and uh while you're fighting him satan
is popping up and saying this is how we
destroy him we deny him and it says do
you wish to deny yahweh yes or no
when he hit yes
he gets hit
i mean that is an interactive bible
study for satan now we have to combat
that i think right yeah i think this is
a great idea to do that right it sounds
like there's two different paths in the
in the gaming world you know there's the
straight narrow and then there's the
white one
and that would definitely be the wide
one extremely demonic too
uh so here's some interesting statistics
to check out uh people watch an average
of 16 hours of online video per
week this is almost like a part-time job
right right you gotta add up the tick
tock hours the netflix and the youtube
and right average this is an interesting
um observation because i mean 16 hours a
week as opposed to you know i mean think
about what you could learn in those 16
hours
if you literally just read a bible topic
16 hours a week i mean in a really short
time you would understand that topic
pretty well man
you've taken it so negative it doesn't
mean that
people are spending 16 hours watching
bad stuff
16 hours a week
yeah i do get a lot of screen time but i
don't watch things that
i have no interest for that other stuff
you know i'm watching
things to learn about things or whatever
yeah but you're probably a rarity yeah i
mean tick tock is full of not good
things
yeah
well tick tock videos are pretty quick
anyways right
that's a lot of videos to be watching in
16 hours it's like 30 second videos
yeah
um interesting of course because of the
recent pandemic uh it's increased by 52
percent over the past two years yeah i
believe it yeah
yeah um viewers retain 95 of a message
when they watch it on a video compared
to 10
when reading it in a text
i think that makes a lot of sense
because there's sounds there's visual
there's i mean there's a lot of um
things for your brain to remember i mean
that's why when you're reading text
right you're you're attaching pictures
so that your brain is is able to digest
that information with the picture right
but you're not talking about an
immersive
you know
you know what in the same veins what you
were talking about like oral
traditions or oral things and then
getting written down it's almost like
the next step of evolution is like well
yeah let's put video with it let's put
sound and music and that would have been
a great thing if we would have continued
to
put bible you know moses what he wrote
into video form but now it's just been
used by the enemy for so many i guess
that makes sense because in a movie it
matches our reality closer to a text
because when we're living i mean you
were in the same room there's sounds
there's visuals there's all of that's
okay it's like putting you there right
and now we're in the future so it's kind
of hard to when you're reading the book
well what was the what was it like in
jesus day well let's show you you know
well speaking of evolution of media i
mean this whole metaverse is going to
open up a whole nother
world to people and be an immersive
um situation you know
yeah i think it's it's a
definitely a negative with the metaverse
but there's a huge positive because this
is a great opportunity to
surround the bible around people that
wouldn't naturally see it often or at
all
in in a in an educating way that they've
never seen that they can be a part of
and even if they're not religious at all
hey a gamer is a gamer right
they'll go play whatever if the content
is there if the story line is there
um assassin's creed is a really good
example of the storyline there's a lot
of history a lot of facts and false
facts also but a lot of people that play
assassin's creed besides the gore and
jumping around and the parkour and stuff
they like to see the history and all
engulfed in in this timeline and they
kind of feel like they're a part of
history on top of that it's like the
best kind of history oh of the game
yeah but there's a real history too like
the
it's like masonic and stuff red cross
and all that i was just thinking about
like what you're saying like the
metaverse
if the metaverse was like this device
that
everything that was on it was bible
study and you come home from work and
you're like oh man i'm going to do some
bible study
and like everything was interactive
cinematic and you're learning bible the
whole time and then after an hour or two
you take it off and that's something
like that would be pretty cool you know
it'd be like you wouldn't see people
like oh i'm just addicted like 24 hours
a day i'm in the metaverse but so what
if you were it was like 24 hours of
bible study you know
if you got addicted to if you got
addicted to studying the bible
what a great thing you know
and my my my key point is to meet people
where they're at like my kids are
wonderful kids i have a 13 year old
daughter and um
she wouldn't really be interested in
this uh her interested is uh and other
things right
um but for some people hey this is a
huge interest and this is maybe even a
crutch in their lives maybe a good
entering wedge to kind of peel
themselves away from the negative things
and closer to jesus i agree it's like
what veggie meets for right yeah you
gotta have those big friends
um so yeah three billion active gamers
by 2023 that's in the numbers are just
going sky high
pretty quickly so are we talking about
like hardcore like console gamers are
you talking about like monthly
average gamers wow right so what
classifies a gamer the person on
facebook doing those those little games
or like whether it's bejeweled console
pc vr
on your cell phone
candy crush yeah
um yeah they're they're all considered
gamers or or even people that don't play
games that watches games that watch
games are also considered gamers yeah
there's people that literally go to
youtube and watch somebody else play a
game yeah well it it's kind of an
interesting concept to give somebody an
alternative something that that they're
learning or teaching them some bible
concepts because you think like a lot of
these people that play candy crush are
gonna play it in a line or while they're
waiting what if you were like learning
prophecy you know what i mean yeah yeah
and i think with this game what's what's
cool is that uh whether you got a
smartphone in india or you know that's
that's you know low grade in quality or
uh
xbox or the newest greatest cell phone
or vr headset that it's cross-platform
so that no matter what device that
you're using even a low quality one um
you can be able to kind of take part of
this epic quest cool awesome uh some
other really interesting uh statistics
that i dug up um
it's definitely a place where a lot of
money is being thrown around is the
gaming industry the average gamer is 34
years old yeah
yeah
i've read that because of gaming when it
kind of hit the population was you know
way back
and so it's it's our generation and up
that kind of started with these things
yeah we've seen them introduced with
atari and nintendo and so yeah i
remember going to my grandmother's house
and playing atari you know playing the
pong and the frogger and stuff like that
and then i got a nintendo when i was
younger and so when it has this 34 years
old i'm thinking of all the consoles
that started coming up in the 80s and
90s and sega genesis and everything and
so i can see how 34 is the average age
70 of gamers are above the age of 18.
that's that's definitely a large
demographic when we're considering our
teenagers and this is this is the
audience too
majority of the world
um
sixty percent of americans play video
games daily
wow over half the population plays every
single day
yeah and there's an average of two
gamers per
uh household i wonder how many americans
read their bible every single day um
that's the point i mean that's that's
personal to me like i don't do it every
day i try to do it almost every day
and what i think is cool about this also
some uh statistics is uh 45 of the us
gamers are women and so it's not like
you're secluding away from a demographic
or a certain culture of people but this
is a wide variety of people it's nearly
a 50 50 cut yeah yeah it is wow so
the thing is with a lot of video games
too and a lot of technology that we have
today is they intentionally make it
addictive so is that a goal when it
comes to the bible because it's like
reading your bible every day how can you
be addicted to that
you know compared to playing a video
game
where it's designed to literally make
you want to come back for more right
um a couple weeks ago i was sitting down
with my bible and i was in genesis 2
right
and i wanted to find out what the four
rivers were in the garden of eden and
what they what it meant and so i just
had this little bible study and it just
came to life for me just just looking up
the definitions of the name of the four
rivers which means to go out go wide and
to multiply i was like oh wow that is
really neat you know there's some good
nuggets in there
uh but not a lot of people have that
opportunity to kind of just sit down
there or choose not to take that
opportunity to sit down and
read their word
but um now that now they'll be able to
um
not just play it but it's going to give
them a reason to go to the pages saying
oh well i saw this in a video game
um i gotta go check out that daniel too
right i need to read it for myself
because i've never seen it like this
right seventy percent of parents believe
video games have a positive influence on
their children's lives whoa are you
serious
after the school shootings and video
games
but there's no link there's no link
i mean the moral the moral decline that
we're seeing around us and the
lawlessness
um i think
now is the time for something like this
yeah i wonder if that's what parents are
thinking well if my kid's sitting here
playing a video game for eight hours a
day at least he's not out there knocking
up a girl or doing drugs or something
you know
or my kid is having trouble finding
community in you know reality at least
he's finding community got 100 friends
right right exactly boosting isn't his
self-esteem
2020 the average um video game based on
how old you are here are some
interesting stats
um it seems like uh whether you're 18
through 45 years old you're probably
going to be spending about an average of
seven hours
playing video games oh wow that's a week
a week yeah about an hour a day yeah
uh an hour of bible study a day yeah
yeah that'd be amazing right
um i i think i think uh we need to give
an impact would that have on the world
uh
school shootings no imagine if if people
replaced that hour a day of shooting
people all day long with reading their
bible what would that do
there's a blogger that is been blogging
about reading the whole bible in 90 days
and as i was kind of listening to that i
was like what you're like read the whole
bible in 90 days that just seems like
like you're reading it all the time and
that's exactly what this blogger was
doing wherever you're waiting in line
you're waiting for somebody at work you
you've got a you know 20 minutes in the
morning
hour in the middle of the afternoon
during your lunch or whatever you know
uh different times throughout the day
and she says it absolutely
revolutionized her walk with god and she
came out of that like just in 90 days
reading the entire bible so now there's
kind of a whole group that that's
jumping on board and doing that and i
thought that was really neat but yeah
it's like we waste a lot of time doing
things that are not profitable to us to
me
it's like that's my that's kind of my
argument with video games is like what
are you really getting out of this like
you play all this stuff and you get all
these points and you get all this like
stuff and you
but what is it what are you actually
achieving at the end of the day so i
think it's kind of neat to see something
that you could be walking away with with
like wow i have this deeper
understanding or knowledge of something
biblical you know you want to go back to
this graph for a second yeah yeah
because i find it the one before
yeah don't you love like the priorities
and dedication of the 18 to 25 like the
older i get i realized i could be so
busy but really i have
never m my business today cannot match
up with the busyness of my high school
years from the moment i wake up to the
moment going to sleep it's either school
something having to do with school
extracurriculars i'm saying get involved
in this just because i want you to stay
busy though finds work for idle hands
there's always something and of course
if someone else is controlling your time
like you have to like go with that as
well and yet they find almost eight
hours in the week to still sit down and
play video games i'm sure that goes down
with time but still
even over 60 um years old
they find at least five hours a week to
play so it's like you know
if you can somehow take that
those priorities that passion to hey i'm
going to do this no matter what i'm
going to get my time in for video games
and kind of flip that to study the word
or even play a bible video game i mean
the impact is there so the time is there
the commitment is there just to harness
that and shift it in the right direction
is is something good
that's interesting because this age
group is also college students
and that's like that was one of the most
stressful times of my life
i was not a fan of all the work that i
had to do on top of that you're also
working yes you know and it's just
really stressful but
i wonder how many in this age group
actually use video games as like a um
like a like a mind-numbing type of thing
just get away with that
type of thing yeah
yeah when i went to uh a christian
college in in the dorm everyone was is
landlines as back in the early 2000s and
such and everyone's landlining and
connecting and playing online video
games and i remember being a part of it
and i found myself playing like horrible
video games like i remember playing
diablo with a bunch of guys and i don't
know if you guys ever played that and
what it's all about but it's a pretty
sadistic game and this was at a
christian school and we were put
investing so much time into playing
video games like basically everyone in
the dorms and uh man i think our grades
could have been a little bit better and
our walk with jesus could have been a
little bit of a team that's right
at the christian dorm everyone's sitting
around playing satan
yeah yeah right
it sounds less intimidating
do you get the satan sauce yeah okay
sounds a little bit scarier that way
uh so this is the kind of the reason why
i want to make it uh cross platform you
know it's got to be for everyone
um when we're looking at different
platforms of playing video games
smartphones have the biggest slice of
the pie with 40 of the market wow um
followed by console games with 28
percent
so are you guys like console or pc users
for video games yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i used to be a console dude but i
haven't played games since then
but yeah everybody is holding this yeah
everybody has this in their hand not
everybody's sitting at a console so
yeah i mean even people that you
wouldn't consider gamers they're like
candy crush or whatever you know they're
solitaire
when i'm driving around uh town early in
the morning i'll see kids waiting at the
bus stop and i'll see people waiting and
what do people do when they're waiting
right there they're texting watching
videos playing some kind of game with
their friends so it seems like what they
do with that down time kind of like what
you were talking about is
yeah different priorities can be made
in case the viewer doesn't realize this
is
a realistic goal where a game is on
every platform right fortnite was on
every platform yeah phone
console computer whatever so this is
doable thing yeah yeah completely doable
um now when we look at the population of
the world of gamers right um believe it
or not united states is not number one
for video games
users population wise we're number three
the main one is in china
uh next surprise that does not surprise
us india surprises me yeah india
surprised me it's funny because um when
i was in hong kong they had this really
cool
like
arcade type thing where
you could literally be in the video
games so like imagine chuck e cheese
before adults except everything's video
games it's not really like you have like
those big ball pits
and so like there was this one um this
one game where you could like they had a
trampoline and so there was like a
camera on your face but it would put you
in the game and so when you're looking
at
it kind of like you're it's like um
there's a flat screen in front of you
and
you have like let's say
like the game that i chose it was like
you jump up and have to hit the birds
but i literally saw myself in the video
jumping up and hitting the birds and i'm
literally jumping as well you don't have
to wear any special glasses or anything
it's just like it's like the real
message off the screen yeah you just
have to be in the game on the screen
it's really really cool wow they make it
so much more fun than whatever they got
going on here
um
have you guys ever heard of twitch
yeah
um some interesting uh stats on twitch
twitch is basically a place where video
gamers go to rebroadcast their video
signal of what they're playing and
themselves and hundreds of thousands of
people come in millions of people come
in to watch other people playing video
games
and some people play video games for a
different reason for entertainment
purposes
or it's enjoying it's what everyone else
is doing so hey why not play that game
so people will watch me they all have
different personalities
and uh just the thing if people are
twitching prophecy quest so not only do
you have the gamer
but you also got the people that are
being a part of it that's interesting
yeah so somebody was a
good personality gets in there and
they're just like oh wow look what i
just found or whatever yeah and even if
it is a negative person personality
and they're going through the scriptures
they might be um trying to hate on it
whatever it might be still you have that
individual playing it along with all of
their followers and then you have this
video that's going to be up for just
people to watch and enjoy that happened
to us yeah with the anime documentary
dude a twitcher a big time twitcher he's
got millions of followers
decided to uh
watch our entire anime and raise money
for an lgbt cause or whatever but he
watched the whole thing and would try to
make fun of it the whole time and most
of the time he he didn't have
valid arguments or whatever it was like
oh look at that animation they did or
whatever he would be jigging on our look
at the font that they used there you
know
i saw thousands of people were what were
exposed to the message that we could
have never reached all those atheists
with yeah it was a million plus
subscribers that literally would not
open their bible that was that was the
kind of the interesting thing to us is
like wow that just got put in front of
people that we actually physically
couldn't reach
and i think that's kind of neat about
what you're talking about even even
looking at this like not and not
necessarily a negative if people go on
there and discuss it you know what i
mean it's like the information still has
to go out and
sometimes those those kind of questions
may spark people to say hey these guys
are making a lot of sense here or this
makes a lot of sense i want to look into
this you know i actually seen that in
the chats that we were talking about the
mark of the beast and we're talking
about how it's not really like something
in your forehead and in your hand like
an implant or something we were talking
about what it really meant
and i saw people in that chat say well
that actually makes sense
and
i just thought of something else too but
yeah like
they're being exposed to it for the
first time they're watching it as a
reaction so imagine somebody's in there
and and they've they're trying to make
fun of it oh yeah jesus this and that
but then they see these beasts and
they're like whoa that's actually pretty
good yeah yeah
well and you were talking about you know
uh the naysayer on the twitch right
and i know uh the video that i did a
while back ago called uh can christians
play fortnite um but i think we got like
25 000 or 30 000 views most critical
because there was this guy that was i
think he ended up getting a hundred
thousand views like that but i mean we
got so much traffic in little live
studios going to can christians play
fortnite and so even though he's just
joking and messing around which he does
you know admit saying hey you know what
i don't think christians should be
playing fortnite so he actually says
okay i can kind of see where they're
getting that while he's
playing and poke and punch satan meant
for evil god is turning around
[Music]
i have a question
what do you think it is about video
games that people
enjoy
i think it's the opportunity to be
something that you want to be or to take
a part of an experience
i think that's the biggest thing that a
gamer is looking for is for the
experience
i think deep down inside we all are are
wanting to to to be a hero and and
overcome a challenge or something like
that you know what i mean like i think
it's just built into us
how can we figure this out how can we
solve this how can we um beat this or do
that you know and and i think um
you know especially some of these games
where they have a boss or something like
that and you have to go battle this
thing right i think deep down inside
just below the surface all of us know
there's something going on around us
and uh i think that's the attraction
that people get involved in all this
because i was thinking is it the
violence given i know a lot of games
aren't violent but i think the ones that
people play most are most violent and
it's interesting because
i mean if we read like as christians we
try to eliminate violence and all the
gory stuff but when we read the bible it
actually is that
so i like
sometimes like when i'm thinking about
when i watch when i like
when you hear a lot of tv shows that are
going on that are very popular um and
they have like a lot of sex a lot of
drugs a lot of just whatever and
it's like
if
if they're like if we take the story of
joseph for example and how um was it
pharaoh's wife who came on to him that
is such an interesting storyline but
it's like we kind of just
you know it's like it's almost it's just
regular people like regular worldly
people who are
is that making sense no no it does
the bible has all kinds of things that
right anything anybody's ever going to
experience right i think the difference
between what sometimes modern media or
entertainment television does is the
bible's giving you a a sort of if this
and this and this happens here's the
result of that
whereas like they're not really doing
that for the movies in fact a lot of
times they're enticing you into that
lifestyle um we just talked about free
guy and it was like the opening thing
the opening scene of free guy is he's
literally like look at this guy he's got
sunglasses and he can go around and
shoot people and do things and he's cool
and look that's not his wife and that's
not his car and he's not going to return
the wife nor the car you know what i
mean he's and he's he's a hero yeah and
i mean that's the message that they're
giving to you whereas the bible's saying
look um
pharaoh's wife or i mean potiphar's wife
you know tried to um entice joseph and
this was the outcome of that and joseph
was faithful to that you know and it's
like it kind of gives you this reason of
of like look these bad things happen but
here's the result of those bad things or
maybe somebody didn't do it badly or
something you know yeah because i know
when i've watched some christian media
it's like
they it's so watered down the story that
it's like you know if there's a married
couple they won't kiss and even though
that's what you do in real life and it's
like just kind of interesting
you know we read these bibles but um
like we read these stories in the bibles
but then
which the world is very familiar with
but then it's like when we translate it
into media it's like the most
uninteresting thing you know we don't
include real elements of life that
you know people want to
i think that's when you make the game
cheesy right yeah exactly
it's got the weird christian vibe and i
think that this is a really good segue
in fact because um let's kind of like
look and see what a christian video game
is right um i went to wiki as anyone
else would do and
they gave the definition for it
christian video games are a game with
christian themes although this
is in itself a game genre most christian
games follow the gameplay of many
different genres
ranges from guitar praise or christian
themed rhythm game to the shooter game
catchment i guess some christian games
with an evangelical proposed that can be
thought of as a serious game but most
christian games are simply entertainment
for players who are already christians
or historically interested in
christianity yeah that makes sense
yeah and i think i think that's that's a
that's a huge negative in regards to
christian games you know if you're if
all you're doing is like okay we're
gonna take a game a copy and paste a
guitar hero and now we're just gonna
rebrand it um you're not actually going
to entertain people or excuse me you're
not actually going to educate people on
the gospels and you know closing their
walk with jesus but all you got is just
game that you can just jam out to and
you're not really evangelizing if the
only people playing it are already
christian christians exactly yeah sure
there'll be some christians who aren't
fully educated on the bible and they'll
learn something but
isn't the goal to
reach new people like fishing for men
right
yeah yeah fishing for the lost not for
the saved but i also think that there is
a need to teach and educate the
christian to know that information so
that they can go out and hopefully like
like if it is brought up on twitch or
something like this you know there's
this community of people that are
discussing this this thing i think
that's kind of you know a good side of
it as well yeah also one more quick um
thing from wiki it says in the 2000s
christian video games were receiving
much criticism
uh being lacking in innovation and
gameplay mechanics because of focusing
too heavily on getting their message
across some christian games were
criticized as being clones of other more
popular games with the bible related
themes and characters simply re-skinned
over the top i remember that in the nes
the original nes there was a game it was
called the bible or something you're
start out as noah and it's literally
like mario like you're just running
around
collecting the animals or whatever i
remember the snakes in the trees yeah
those six i mean they should totally
reskin fortnite right you run around and
you just help people and you you take
your neighbors trash out and you know i
mean people would love that side of the
road and you give them some money and
help them build their houses
yeah
you know um i think that jesus is coming
real soon and not to put a date on that
but i think that um our walk with him is
very important and so is the world's
walk with him because when it comes down
to it these are individuals these are
souls and these are people that need
christ in a relationship with him and
this is a huge opportunity to be able to
put the gospels in front of their eyes
we're talking about how exciting bible
prophecy can be and mikey you're talking
about the beast of daniel chapter 7 and
you're talking about how gory some
things can be and but even the bible can
be intense within itself
when we look at the lion
it's more than just lion we always see
pictures of a beautiful lion you know
kind of like a narnia kind of thing
but there's this um website that
similitude kind of was a part of and
they made four life-size beasts and
they're not happy-go-lucky beautiful
beast but oh the the lion literally has
a human heart coming out of its chest
wow yeah and it looks it looks kind of
interesting and then the fourth piece
it's like mucking up with blood and gump
inside of its mouth and so it makes it a
lot more visual not saying that that's
what we need in a video game in order
for it to be appealing but
there is an honest factor that needs to
be attached to the scriptures which i'm
sure in any video game you can regulate
the gore or what the intensity of of the
game based on the age i also think that
like that
you know showing those physical beasts
like the similitude um you know jason
yeah he's he's actually brought one of
those beasts around here and we got a
chance to like go see that thing in
action yeah we should link it we'll look
at that video in the description yeah
we brought it to walmart
just to see how people walking by would
react to this thing and i mean people
were stopping like taking pictures of
this thing like what was it like like a
full life-sized beast from revelation
yeah walmart just right
tracks right there yeah parked it right
in the front yeah where you would like
wait for somebody to bring a tv out or
something yeah it was a harlot riding a
seven headed beast and it was awesome i
mean dude cops would drive by stop what
do you what whoa this is cool you know
like gotta get a selfie yeah and so then
they would be in questioning it and then
he would have um some way of saying well
if you want to look more into this snap
this qr code it'll bring you to like a
revelation seminar it's it's a great
idea
but this can kind of be that same sort
of thing it's not going to appeal to
everybody
but you know i mean there are going to
be people that are naturally
inquisitive about this and want to look
deeper into it
what i like about that is that
god being the god of all creativity
there's no reason why the world stuff
should look better than christians yeah
you know but it's like i think also
what's what some people experience in
the church when trying to be creative is
like the church kind of shuns it so then
they get stuck with all the cheesy stuff
and then people end up leaving to work
for hollywood because that's where their
creativity is embraced and i get i get
the church's fear you know you don't
want to make things too worldly because
you know sometimes the things that do
appeal to the youth are kind of like you
know you just can't let people do
whatever they want to in the church
because in the church they're just going
to be taking like tech talk videos and
just making them christian and you know
so but yeah i think that's really
encouraging just with the beast thing
that you can have something
that's biblical but also so interesting
that can grab people's attention you
know
i think i think the gospel or the bible
in itself is clear enough to be able to
grab people's attention and the focus of
it
um i think a lot of it is support and
finances i mean i wish there was a poll
of just christians how much money
are christians investing into hollywood
and how much are those same christians
investing into a ministry yeah
yeah do you have a gaming console at
home because how much are those games
they're like 50 bucks pieces right how
much is
or 40 for that game or the
20 movie ticket you know
christmas shopping yeah even christmas
shopping people got new devices yeah
yeah
um
so in regards to the message and the
focus i think of today's time um i think
we are living in the end times and
there's a huge focus that's needed
especially on in bible prophecy
something called the three angels
message like that should be the primary
focus of
that we need to be giving to the world
today and when we look at revelation 1
chapter 1 revelation chapter 1 verse 1
it kind of paints a really cool picture
as to what bible prophecy really is it
says the revelation of jesus christ the
word revelation in the greek just
literally means to
uh reveal and so bible prophecy is all
about revealing jesus
um in fact it's what brought me into the
church when i was 15 years old there was
an amazing facts revelation series my
friends invited me out um
i
i was uh not a protestant at the time
and i was definitely opening
a month worth i mean every single day
hour after hour maybe even three hours
in one day i was learning bible prophecy
and i was coming back when i was 15
years old because i'm like this is jesus
this is the word of god this is way this
is truth for today
um and revelation 1 verse 1 it says uh
it's this message is for the servants of
today
of things that are shortly going to come
to pass
and when we consider the message that's
needed to be given and the people that
are going to be receiving it
um there's a sad factor because of the
distractions of today
hosea 4 6 puts it like this my people
are destroyed for lack of knowledge
because thou has rejected knowledge i
will also reject thee that thou shalt be
no priest to me seeing thou has
forgotten the law of god i will also
forget thy children
and so we kind of see during you know
the moral decline in the in the area
where we live today uh the focus of
knowledge of what people want to be
focusing on you know maybe some people
would rather be focusing on spacex and
pig transplants and tapping into the
brain and such maybe that's everyone's
focus today
but the focus should be the true
knowledge
daniel talks about that knowledge a
little bit it says uh daniel 2 12 4 says
but you daniel shut up the words and
seal the book until the time of the end
that's today many shall run to and fro
knowledge shall increase and it's not
just worldly knowledge
but it's the knowledge of the word
and here we have a possible like
i mean i'm still developing it it's so
fresh and it's a new concept
but
could you imagine beyond being able to
put a revelation series in front of the
world's hands where they can know and
understand the scriptures of bible
prophecy in the
uh whether it's the rapture uh the mark
of the beast
um
the lies of the antichrist such as you
know hell burning burning forever and
ever or
loved ones going straight to heaven or
hell or being able to communicate with
the ghost but um
this bible prophecy app is going to be
able to bring a lot of clarity
especially when satan's supposed to be
coming here real soon to kind of confuse
the masses
i don't know if you're going to get into
this but what what is some of the
can you paint a picture for us like how
this game would play out or what kind of
ideas you have for
teaching these
um
principles and stuff paint the picture
right all right uh so obviously i don't
have that much concept and video concept
the jason with similitude he's working
on this concept of the first level and i
had 10 minutes written out with with my
friend patrick and then i get in contact
with jason and then he goes jared i want
to show you something he hasn't even
seen my script basically it's my first
level and he's already done it in 3d and
everything i was like
dude we have the exact same concepts and
i sent over my document goes
wow so
yeah i think i think that while making a
video game like this the lord will use a
whole bunch of different people and not
just one person to be able to create
this bible prophecy video game and you
said there'll be different levels of
intensity for different age groups yeah
that way yeah yeah well um you know
obviously my daughter is 13 and there's
a lot of things that i would not want
her to be focusing on
maybe yeah just just basically the
intensity and they can kind of
down it down or level it up and such
okay so it'll be like different versions
yeah yeah okay it'll be probably an easy
way to do that is if in the beginning
um if they enter their name and stuff
they could probably choose their age um
but if they do it in the beginning then
it's not like they're gonna think
so exactly and getting that survey in at
the at the beginning is very important
because as they go along through the
game
um they might put themselves as a
christian that knows a little bit about
the bible or a lot about the bible and
then they can be able to reevaluate
themselves
or you know if they want to be in
contact with a local ministry that might
be able to provide some other uh study
study materials then um hey we can be
able to get them in contact with those
people
that's awesome because it'll know their
location and be like oh wow you're just
like five minutes down the road from an
awesome church they'll teach you all
this stuff or what if there's an awesome
church that's down the road that's
having a cooking class or a revelation
series hey i got this cool video game
installed onto my phone and now i'm
receiving a notification saying that
there's a revelation series just down
the road i think i'm gonna go check that
out especially if this game is
suggesting it yeah
oh i like that it becomes like an actual
physical social thing instead of just
staying online yeah
and you would kind of explain to me some
of the some of the
aspects of the game like when you first
start you're in like a cave and like
yeah yeah yeah can you tell a little bit
about that yeah i'll uh paint a level a
little bit better so um imagine the dent
or
imagine this level where there's two
walls of a cliff right and you have to
get to the other cliff
so
the pathway that's on each cliff is very
narrow
and so from one side of a cliff you have
to get to the other side so you have a
let's say a rope bridge that's going out
to the middle of a floating island so
during the time of this rope bridge
you're learning trust in god as you're
you know uh maybe the rope is falling
and then you go up to the top where the
floating island is at
and then there you can be able to see
the um building where you learn the
armor of god and then after you learn
that now you have these two paths that
are given
and then you can take the wide path to
the world or you can take the narrow
path which leads to the other side of
the mountain when you get to the narrow
path which long which is on the other
side it gets more narrow and more narrow
and morning
until a tightrope yeah right until uh
maybe you just have to wait for a golden
rope to drop down from the top nice
yeah
in the daniel 2 level which is probably
one of my favorite ones imagine you're
talking to daniel face to face
and daniel's like hey i want to tell you
about a dream that i had and you're
actually able to go into those
experiences that they've experienced so
daniel is actually going to be telling
you about daniel too or maybe moses will
might actually be letting you know about
the sanctuary and everything else that's
inside the sanctuary which i think has a
lot to do with bible prophecy absolutely
yeah and so when the computers talk to
you they're not talking to you as if hey
adventurer or anything else like that no
nothing corny
what if to kind of break the fourth wall
what if they talk to you knowing that
you're using a device um wow
like they know you're in the future
looking back through some vr and stuff
yeah yeah that's pretty cool
do you picture like a it's a hologram
talking to you or
um everything is lifelike triple a
graphics and it's as if you're there so
you're going to be jumping through
prophecy whether it's in the old
testament new testament and also during
the time of the reformers
uh during the persecution of the
christian church the 1260 years and
you're able to see those reformers and
what they went through while learning
all these bible prophecy troops there's
a there's a children's christian cartoon
it's not super book oh yeah story teller
nested
no no
yeah but nested family videos or
whatever i read is the story no story
keeper is there in bible times during
like the roman empire is it a video game
no it's a show
for kids i don't know what you're
talking about though it but like they
stepped into
i know you're talking about it it was
older
yeah they would supervise no
it was um oh it's like super book but
it's kind of like magic school bus
it reminds me yeah
it would take you through the history
mm-hmm it's a little bit like super book
but it's the old school super book right
now no it was three little children yeah
and they would go
they were like digging in the ground and
they fell down yeah yeah yeah
what is that is it is that
the greatest heroes oh yeah one of your
greatest great adventures in the box
yeah do i even air that anymore
but think about how that captivated
people where you have this you know
interesting
you got a funny guy you got a logical
thinker and you're going through the
stories of the bible and learning them
right but i think that was during the
70s wasn't it was it
wow yeah santa barbara probably 70 80s
showing my age
it would be cool to um
like
i mean just an idea if
they can also become one of the
characters like for example if you are
daniel in the lion's den and there are
choices that you can make
you can try to climb out
you can try to find a rock and hit the
lion but then it's like what is our
first impulse when what we're really
supposed to be doing is trusting in god
you know that'd be kind of cool i i like
that idea and i've thought about that
concept too um whether you're talking
with the person or if you are that
person
so then you can be able to transfer
your viewing angle and you're the way
you're thinking differently so now
instead of being the learner you are now
the uh
learned yeah yeah he could be talking to
you and you're seeing him let me tell
you about when i was in the lion's den
and all of a sudden like you are in the
lines then you're looking around and
we're talking about this being on vr too
right yeah yeah and
i don't know if you guys have seen the
new matrix trailer have you guys seen
the new matrix video game trailer
it's just mind-blowing in regards to the
graphics and what they're doing because
in the gameplay you're transferring
yourself from one pl from one character
to the other character to the other
character now to be honest it doesn't
take that much skill to play it i don't
know if you looked at it but i'm going
to show you here soon
and it's more of just being a part of an
interactive movie or something
absolutely
you are now uh neo yeah in an industry
where actors have tried to remain
perpetually young
we wondered about digital faces that
could become immortal
hi i'm carrie anne moss and i played
trinity in the matrix films 20 years ago
we asked ourselves how long it would be
before faces and bodies could be changed
as easily how old were you during the
matrix
and what does reality mean
i'm not going to share my age
so
they're talking about being
3d being a 3d world but it's also
talking about hey this is also lifelike
now it's merging the worlds of video
game and movies and edutainment is now
it's like one big melting pot
um when we look at the formats that we
have right now in regards to reaching
people with uh the beautiful messages of
the word of god and bible prophecy
um right now it's kind of it's kind of
limited we've got some wonderful tracks
to hand out glow tracks i love i'm a
bible worker personally in lexington i
also do video edits and working with
little light every now and then and
um
but i love handing out glow tracks
nothing i mean anywhere you want to go
you can hand out a glow track there's a
glow track for any any reason of the
season
um but you know it just doesn't stop
there there's a satellite there's roku
there's youtube there's so many
different revenues um
but you know those revenues are kind of
starting to be outdated
and um i don't know anyone that has a
roku
i have one oh you do you really my dad
maybe if you're 40 and above
no um
so these are great um
tools to be used for
for the message but um i don't think it
stops there i think we should be able to
broaden the horizon a little bit
and um
so i do have a bible prophecy video game
that i do want to make uh scottie thank
you so much um for just wanting to
support this vision yeah um i have other
people that are like saying jared this
is awesome this is you know something
that needs to be done uh have you guys
ever heard of gyc generation youth
christ yeah all right uh recently i had
this epic big huge booth there i had two
vr headsets going uh big screen tv kind
of doing a loop of my trailer and just
kind of talking with the people there
and there was just lines of kids wanting
to play the vr and then their parents
what are they going to do right they
want to hang out with me and just chat
it up
and what i've been learning is that even
at gyc
when i go and ask these kids
hey have you ever you know studied bible
prophecy and been to like a revelation
series or you know watched a revelation
series online
and almost a quarter of them said no
i've never seen it and i've never been
to a revelation series
and this is the youth of of today
that are supposed to be um the future
yeah yeah i'd probably say in the world
since there's probably been a lot less
of the christian population that's been
exposed to that so
but what does it take you know to make
this dream a reality because you have
the concept and you have a graphic
designer it sounds like what but when it
comes to the technical stuff what help
do you need if at all yeah yeah um well
i've got a list of supporters on props
sequest.net
and scotty's one of them
and i also have some amazing facts
evangelists uh wyatt allen
uh pastor steve wohlberg with white
horse media
ryan day with amazing facts what was
with and now with 3abn
um daniel hudgins another really good
evangelist and um so i don't want to
water down
the message at all
but if you want to support you can see
my supporters on the prophecyquest.net
website and to be honest right now it's
all concept um it's what i think about
all day i i wake up thinking about it i
go to sleep thinking about it
and it's what my conversations are all
the time my wife has to say i'm i don't
want to talk anymore this is the main
focus
um
also so you can go to the website it's
definitely going to take a little bit to
kind of get the non-profit going um
that's in the works right right now so
that people can be able to donate a
little bit more easily
and um what i would like to do is be
able to make a concept the concept is
probably going to cost about a hundred
thousand just to create the concept and
the only reason it's so high is because
it's that much in depth it's not gonna
be cheaply done okay a hundred thousand
actually isn't a lot of money compared
to what they dump into secular video
games well well it's concept yeah
yeah and it's just like a little taste
of it now in regards to uh the normal
priced video game i'm not going to say
how much this is going to cost
eventually i'll get to that point but
when you look at the normal video game
assassin's creed call of duty the big
ones right
rockstar grand theft auto you're looking
at 47 to 175 million wow and that's just
to develop
that is a lot wow right
but it's not a lot for god right
this is his word and he wants it out for
sure so he'll provide
yeah yeah definitely um
so not only do i have really good
supporters um on on the website but
there's another supporter that's not on
there um who's been giving me a lot of
guidance have you ever heard of esports
yes not ea sports just esports yeah yeah
i have heard of esports because you you
brought them up to me right so uh
esports is basically competitive gaming
um and it's a multi-billion dollar
company in industry come to find out the
ceo of esports
um goes goes to my church uh
that's awesome right that's crazy yeah
and someone said hey um danny is his
name you gotta check out this video game
it looks like a pretty cool idea come to
find out the ceo of esports is like i've
always wanted to make a christian video
game
so he's he's given me a lot of direction
and things that i need to accomplish and
hooking me up with the right person um
so are you looking for any
anyone to help or do you have all the
supporters you need i need a lot of
support
i have no support uh you know just just
getting the couple grand just for um a
non-profit it's pretty hard
uh
i'm a bible worker so that those kind of
figures are a little bit high for me but
if there's anyone that wants to help
i need your help they can donate through
your website
yeah definitely through the prophecy i'm
just sitting here thinking about all
those kids that went to that booth and
were yeah this is so cool you know like
how much is it how much is it worth for
their eternal you know this is we're
talking about eternity here learning the
bible learning bible truths trying to
keep kids away from all these violent
video games that are doing nothing for
learning the bible man like this is this
is a big deal like a lot of people would
just see this and be like yeah cool idea
but i'm not going to invest in it and
this is something that we should really
think about it is a good investment i
know you guys are feeling the pain right
now of buying fruits and vegetables in
grocery stores with inflation but i keep
telling myself i rather spend money on
good food to eat that than spend
thousands of dollars in the medical bill
later so it's like changing the mindset
how do you want to invest in the future
in children and even in the church right
now at present and and pushing the
gospel all over the world
well i think this is a beautiful idea
man and i really hope that um there's a
lot of people out there that are going
to see the value of something like this
and get in contact with you and for sure
push this thing forward because i
believe time is short
and so you know this is a this is a
really great way to meet people where
they're at that we maybe potentially
don't have the opportunity to just sit
down and teach them something biblical
you know this might be a really great
way or a first introduction to it to
them and could be life-changing
yeah yeah definitely what is the
possibility that something like this if
it did happen
what would be the impact on the world
worldwide right when it does
amen
um yeah yeah if you look at the impact
of the world uh not just here in the
states uh in all the christianity
looking at it but you also have people
from india
and you have people from china or you
know areas where it's hard to receive
this kind of bible truth that's right
you're not just going to walk in there
and and give an evangelistic series
you're probably taken to jail so you
gotta figure out new ways to get in
there and maybe even kind of overt ways
you know because the military the police
and stuff they see
you can't just mail bibles in there
either but a video game called prophecy
quest interesting bring it in
well i know that prisoners anyways or
inmates excuse me um a lot of them have
cell phones also
while they're inside so hey if they want
to download the game
well i kind of want to end it on this
note this guy his name is brother s
brother s is a cool guy during the late
1800s early 1900s he thought out of the
box
and he loved jesus and he believed that
jesus was coming soon and so he took all
the beasts of daniel seven
and eight and basically he brought him
into his evangelism series so that
people can you know it could be more
tangible not only that but hey i'm gonna
come out to see these crazy looking bees
that look pretty cool right
so you said he was doing this in what
the 18th
late 1800s early 1900s wow and yeah he
was thinking outside the box this was
his wow his draw to the gospel and we
can see how god it has been working
throughout
human history to make the bible come
alive to people and for there to be a
deeper understanding and today we need
to do the same we need to come up with
these concepts and ideas to to get
people on board
you said we must
and i love that
let me read this quote
let every worker in the master's
vineyard study
plan devise methods to reach the people
where there they are
we must do something out of the common
course of things
we must arrest the attention we must be
deadly in earnest we are on the very
verge of times and trouble and
perplexities that are scarcely dreamed
up
i i think that moment is now
right
and uh i think as we go through time um
these bees life-size bees are going to
be used more and more often to kind of
captivate the audiences too i mean we
saw firsthand like just the audience it
grabbed at walmart for a short 30
minutes i mean
imagine if you took that all over
and now
you don't have to go
physically you can just put your headset
on and see these beasts in in real life
and what i also like about the approach
that this is doing is it sometimes is
very intimidating especially if
someone's not used to church
maybe it's not cool you don't think it's
cool with your friends or whatever yeah
yeah
there's a variety of issues on why
somebody would walk into a church
and um this you can do in the privacy of
your own home you know in your own time
and it's like you know you're kind of
removing those barriers that would that
would inhibit somebody from from doing
that and you're just giving them feeding
them the information that's why you said
in your own time because
not every church is open at 3am right
right and you're right because you never
know who's watching i saw the video of
you that you guys took at um walmart and
people recognized you like hey you're
familiar and these these are
non-christian people
so it's like imagine
you know all of heaven is is fighting
this war for every soul so imagine here
on earth if we're kind of getting people
from every angle so on youtube they're
watching little i and they've signed
into a video game and they get prophecy
quest and like at each angle they're
being introduced to jesus until they
finally make that decision hey i'm going
to start studying for myself i mean how
powerful is that yeah
i love it and i i love that it's like no
matter where you're at you can be a part
or take part of something and learn
something and then grow from it
i remember scotty you told me one time
that you had um
i don't know if it's in out in africa or
something like that but you learned that
someone had a cd or a dvd player
what's what's that story
well i mean there there there is
limited
media things in the world and i've been
to a few third world countries and um
but it's very interesting that these
people still have tvs they still have
video game consoles i mean i've been to
brazil in almost the jungle and and
asked people you know you play in these
video games and and you know these
little hands would go up yeah they're
all playing the video game so even if we
would think that the world out there
doesn't have this access to this
technology it's not the case um a lot of
the world has access to it yeah i've
seen a worldwide known evangelist on tv
saying that
he preaches up many different places and
he when he goes these third world
countries they run up to him oh we watch
you every day and he's looking he's like
you're living in a tin
like shack with dirt for a floor but
they all have phones and somehow have
connection wi-fi or whatever so
this is how the gospel is going to reach
the ends of the world man like the
everywhere because you can't enter into
all those places physically but
you're talking about digital man you're
talking about airwaves and we got to get
in there and do this stuff man i think
it's a great idea
me too
awesome well i really hope much success
in this area and uh you know we'll be uh
rooting for you and i know this thing's
gonna cost a million dollars when it
gets out right
i mean what's the price point here
right well um well you know 100 thousand
to uh to be able to design a concept no
the price point to if i want to get the
video game oh if you want to buy it yeah
100 bucks free free free free
so wait you're gonna make this whole
thing
freely available to people yes that's
impressive even yeah yeah definitely
there's such a huge population out there
why why limit them um if anyone wants to
donate hey that's that's great but i
think the main focus should be getting
this message out to the people before
jesus comes amen
very cool we hope you guys were blessed
by today's led live with jared bowling
and prophecyquest.net
check him out look him up um this is a
really interesting unique way to
evangelize and you know if you guys are
curious about the impact video games
have on you we have some documentaries
that we've created on the video game
topics
these are more or less coming from a
perspective of the sort of negative side
of video games and video games are very
powerful we believe that they are
teaching tools but what are they
teaching you so that's discussed in a
lot of these um you can get them on
little lightstudios.tv
you can check out some of our clips and
float through our youtube page here and
uh we've got little snips of some of
these videos so if you want to like
sample um and see what those are about
check them out but thank you guys for
tuning in we hope you guys were blessed
and we'll see you next week
[Music]
you